[Music]
it's not that easy to categorize jobs
but here's a categorization scheme
that's kind of general but that's
actually accurate okay so the first
dimension is complexity jobs range from
simple to complex a simple job is one
that you can learn and then repeat okay
you don't need high levels of cognitive
function for a simple job if if you have
high levels of cognitive function you'll
learn the job faster but once you learn
it you won't necessarily do it better
okay but now a complex job is one where
the requirements change on an ongoing
basis so most managerial jobs are like
that and all executive jobs are like
that and that requires a high level of
general cognitive ability that's the
best predictor of success in complex
jobs okay so that's that's access number
one access number two is creative slash
entrepreneurial versus managerial slash
administrative okay so for creative
entrepreneurial jobs you need people who
are high in the trait personality trait
openness to experience big five
personality trait that's associated with
lateral and divergent thinking and those
are creative types and for managerial
and administrative jobs and those are
jobs that are more algorithmic and so
like imagine the guardrails you're a
train on a track and you want to go down
the track fast you don't have to be
creative to go down a track that's
already laid down fast you have to be
conscientious and so the best predictor
personality predictor for managerial and
administrative jobs is trait
conscientiousness okay so there's a
tension in organizations between lateral
and divergent thinking and efficient
movement forward now if you know what
you're doing what you want is
conscientious people because if you know
what you're doing you should just do it
as efficiently as you can
but the problem is is the world changes
around you unexpectedly and so if you
don't have people who can think
divergently
when the marketplace shifts on you which
it most certainly will then you don't
have anybody who can figure out where to
lay new tracks now it's really really
difficult for people for corporations to
get the balance between the entre
proneural creative types and the
managerial administrative types correct
and what I think happens and I don't
know this for sure and the research on
this isn't clear yet what seems to
happen is that when a company originates
the creative entrepreneurial types
predominate and they have to be flexible
and move laterally to to get the company
established to begin with and take risks
and break rules and do all sorts of
things that conscientious people are
much less likely to be able to tolerate
let alone think up but as the company
establishes itself the managerial
administrative types pour in and take
over but if they take over too much then
the company gets so rigid it can't it
has no flexibility okay so so the first
thing you need to do to manage a large
enterprise is to understand that these
are actually different people okay so
first of all everyone is not creative
that's a lie there's so we we
established this measurement instrument
called the creative achievement
questionnaire which is very widely used
in creativity research now okay and what
you see so what it does is it breaks
down creativity into 13 dimensions
entrepreneurial architectural literary
dramatic inventions etc business you can
imagine painting etc imagine the 13
potential dimensions of creativity and
then it ranks order levels of creativity
from zero I have no training or talent
in this area to ten I have an
international reputation in this area
okay and then we plotted the scores okay
this is the distribution okay it's not a
normal distribution sixty percent of the
people who take the creative achievement
question questionnaire score zero right
a tiny minority have high scores and
that's that's that's a Pareto
distribution
it's a classic distribution of human
productivity so you always get a Pareto
distribution not a normal distribution
when you're talking about productivity
creative people are a distinct minority
they're a different kind of person and
they're a pain they're a pain because
you can't evaluate
right it's like how the hell do you
evaluate a creative person because they
keep changing the rules of evaluation so
they're they're uh they're uh they're a
handful to manage and they're always
trying to play a new game well that's a
real pain if you want to get somewhere
fast so if there's this terrible tension
in organizations and I think what
generally happens is all the creative
people are there at the beginning they
get chased out until you have nothing
but managers and administrators then the
environment shifts then the company dies
and so the way that capitalism solves
the problem of the tension between the
creative types and the managerial types
is it just lets companies die now you
might think well I don't want my company
to die it's like okay then you would
need to understand the difference
between these two kinds of people which
you probably won't and you probably
won't admit to even if you knew and then
you have to figure out how to get the
balance right and so that's
extraordinarily complicated so
[Music]